- [Voiceover] Now that
we've read the passage
let's see if we can answer the questions.
In the context of the passage,
the author's use of the
phrase her light step flying
to keep time with his long
stride, lines four to five,
is primarily meant to
convey the idea that?
So, that's right over
here, lines four to five.
So, her light step,
her light step flying to keep time
with his long stride.
So, remember, this is,
Mattie Silver had lived under
Ethan's roof for a year,
and from early morning
till they met at supper
he had frequent chances of seeing her,
but no moments in her company
were comparable to those when.
So, he's talking about a really good time
when her arm in his,
and her light step flying to keep
time with his long stride.
They walked back through
the night to the farm.
So, you kind of imagine,
he's this guy and he's,
these long strides,
and he's not used to being
kind of connected to people
and being happy around people,
but then there's her and her light step
flying to keep time with his.
So, you imagine this
person and they're kind
of having this enthusiastic
and spirited conversations.
I mean, we read the whole
passage about nature,
and about science, and about
feeling this connection.
So, yeah, this first
choice Ethan and Mattie
share a powerful enthusiasm.
That looks like what's being described.
I mean, in fact as we read on we realize
that's at least what Ethan at
the time thought was going on.
B, Mattie strives to match the speed
at which Ethan works.
Well, no, that would be the case if, like,
they were saying that
he has these long stride
and she was having trouble,
and the whole passage was about her having
trouble doing all the work in the house
that she wants him to do and all of that.
But that's not what it's about.
The whole passage is about
this powerful enthusiasm
and it really starts
from these early lines
where we're talking about this is the time
that he liked being around
her and this connection
and her light steps flying to keep
time with his long stride.
You kinda, they've having fun,
the spirited, passionate
conversations in the night.
Mattie and Ethan playfully
compete with each other.
Compete, well, no, the
spirit of competition
doesn't really play out here.
In fact, most of what
he kind of talks about,
he likes being like this
teacher, professorial figure,
this father figure kind of that likes
to awaken her appreciation of the planet.
So, it doesn't really
seem like a competitive
or even a playfully
competitive relationship.
It's really, she, he's the teacher.
At least, he thinks he's the teacher
and she's the student who's
appreciating him and nature.
Ethan walks at a pace
that frustrates Mattie.
Well, nothing in the passage makes us
think that, or at least in the beginning,
that Mattie somehow got
frustrated by Ethan.
It sounds like, at least
over in those times,
when he's reminiscing
about it that he believes
that she was really enjoying all of this.
So, I would definitely go with A.
Let's go to the next question.
The description in the first paragraph
indicates that what Ethan values
most about Mattie is her...
Fitness for farm labor.
No, he, in fact, he says right over here,
"She don't look much on housework."
So, it's not gonna be that.
Vivacious youth.
That's possible.
I mean, she is this
kind of youthful spirit
that's entered into this life.
Receptive nature, freedom from worry.
So, the receptive nature
is interesting too
because he talks in
the whole passage about
how open she is about learning
about the stars and about geology
and whatever else.
Well, let's just see.
"But she don't look much on housework
"but she ain't a fretter, anyhow."
But then they say, "But it was not only
"that the coming to his house of a bit
"of hopeful young life was like
"the lighting of a fire on a cold breath."
So, he's saying it was't only
essentially her vivacious youth.
"The girl was more than the bright
"serviceable creature he had thought her.
"She had an eye to see and an ear to hear.
"He could show her things
and tell her things,
"and taste the bliss of feeling
"that all he imparted
left long reverberations,
"reverberations and echoes
he could wake at will."
So, this is, it starts off saying,
look, it didn't look
like she was necessarily
the most impressive to look
at from a labor point of view
and sure, she had vivacious
youth but that wasn't it.
The really powerful thing about her
is she had an eye to
see and an ear to hear.
He could show her things,
and tell her things,
and taste the bliss of feeling that all
he imparted left long reverberations
and echoes he could wake at will.
So, really, it is about
the receptive nature.
She was open to these things
and he wanted to teach her, and she was,
at least he thought,
excited about these things.
Question four, which choice provides
the best evidence for the
answer to the previous question?
Well, actually I would, I
would, I would, let's see.
I think I highlighted them.
She had, she had,
the girl was more than the bright
serviceable creature he had thought her.
She had an eye to see and ear to hear.
He could show her things
and tell her things.
So, let's see.
Which of these are that?
This is, like, line 15 through 16, 17, 18.
That's, actually, I highlighted,
happened to highlight those exact lines.
I like to these, as you can tell,
in real time so that I am experiencing
it as you would experience it.
But luckily, I literally,
well, anyway, you get the point.
This is the line that tells,
these are the lines that
say that she was receptive.
She had an eye to see and an ear to hear.
He could show her things
and tell her things.
So, definitely go with that.
The author includes the
descriptions of the sunset,
the clouds, and the hemlock shadows.
Hemlock is a type of plant.
So, the shadows of the
plants says we're in nature.
So, lines 41, 43.
So, let's go down to line 41.
Line 41, 43, and I'll start
reading a little early.
And there were other sensations.
Less definable but more
exquisite. More exquisite.
So, before we was talking about
kind of science of the stars
and being able to think about
what's in the fossil
record and all of that,
but then they were saying there were
other sensations less
definable but more exquisite,
which drew them together
with the shock of silent joy.
The cold red of sunset
behind the winter hills,
the flight of cloud-flocks
over slopes of golden stubble,
or the intensely blue shadows
of hemlock on sunlit snow.
When she said to him once,
"It looks just as if it was painted."
So, this is just kind of that incredible,
I mean, I feel that maybe I should have
hung out with Ethan Frome (laughs)
but when you're in nature there's this
indescribable feeling of how
it just connects with you.
The beauty of it all.
So, this is what they're
describing over here
when we're talking about the sunset,
the clouds, the hemlock shadows.
So, it suggests the peacefulness
of the natural world.
Oh yeah.
Emphiase the acuteness of
two characters' sensations.
Yeah, I like that because he's talking
about him in the past as we read it
that he was wondering
is he the only person
who feels so strongly about nature
and the beauty of the natural world
but he's, at the time he said,
"I think I found someone in this Mattie,
"who connects with this sensation,
"who understands it."
Foreshadowing the decline of
the fortunes of two characters.
No, this isn't that.
This is about their connection.
Offer a sense of how fleeting time can be.
No, this was about both of them,
him feeling this very basic
passion for everything around him,
this almost indescribable thing,
and her connecting with it.
And when she says, "It looks
just as if it was painted."
He feels that she had
just perfectly described
what he was feeling these sensations.
So, I definitely, I
definitely would go with B.